ensuite en face à la grande terre de la
semaine c'est la revue
[Musique]
nature et caro bonsoir alors vous êtes
philosophe photographe spécialiste de
génétique cellulaire moines bouddhistes
alors je précise pour les fans des
marseillais à miami que bouddhiste ne
veut pas dire que vous boudez
à
alors moine bouddhiste mais aussi moins
médiatique vous avez vendu des centaines
de milliers de livres mais ce que
beaucoup de gens ne savent pas c'est que
les droits d'auteur sont intégralement
reversés à chaque fois à votre
organisation humanitaire qui s'appelle
karuna chez chaîne v fondée en 2000 et
qui aident aujourd'hui quatre cent mille
personnes en inde au tibet au népal dans
des écoles dans des dispensaires dans
des cliniques il vous reste rien pas
juste de quoi me déplacer ou enfin je
n'ai pas besoin mounir mitage fait neuf
mètres carrés sans chauffage j'ai pas de
voiture pas de terrain pas de maison et
puis en plus on n'est pas on va pas
faire de piscine de ses enfants
les ferrari circulent je n'ai vraiment
pas besoin ça serait plutôt des ennuis
qu'autre chose et vous
vous dites je n'ai pas de maison à part
votre petit ermitage évidemment j'ai en
tout et pour tout trois paires de
chaussures une pour ici et deux pour le
népal où je vis six mois par an voilà
c'est dénuement absolu mais non c'est la
simplicité volontaire et heureuse moine
bouddhiste mais aussi moines médiatique
on l'a dit à la télévision vous dites
c'est pour mes projets humanitaires que
je fais le clown dans les médias vous l
impression de faire le clown chers comme
les gens ils pas toujours le moine
hypermédiatisé vous avez dit l'homme le
plus heureux du monde c'est la plus
grosse blague de la planète enfin bon
c'est pas grave si vous voulez en fait
des fois même dire qu'il me manque
quelques pourquoi est ce que vous venez
quand vous ne mangez pas vous m'avez
demandé de venir je suis assise non je
suis tranquille dans mon ami tu as en
fait c'est très simple il ya deux
raisons une parce qu'il ya des idées qui
me sont extrêmement chères et qui je
pense peut être utile à partager ne
serait ce sur l'altruisme la coopération
la bienveillance le fait d'être un peu
moins l'esclave de nos toutes nos
émotions destructrice et ensuite
effectivement quand je suis dans mon nez
un mitage me dis pourquoi je redescends
c'est beaucoup pour soutenir ses projets
humanitaires que j'ai commencé dans le
chien peut lire le visent ce public donc
le clown et puis aussi maintenant que je
prends de l'âge l'idée peut-être de
fonder une fondation qui malheureusement
porte mon nom si vous voulez que les
gens continuent à donner de l'argent est
connu que le porte si vous laissez un
peu l'épidémie du narcissisme et dans
mon cas c'est plutôt pour que ça ça
perdure après mois les idées sur le vers
une société plus altruiste cas peut-être
des actions en france pour ceux qui sont
dans le besoin et continuer nos actions
en asie alors voeu de pauvreté mais
aussi voeu de chasteté
alors bien sûr vous avez des aventures
amoureuses jusqu'à votre en temps vous
avez même failli vous marier comme vous
aviez 21 ans vous savez tout oui mais
depuis votre ordination en
1978 il ya donc 40 ans no sex non meyer
ceci dit c'est forcément on a des
affinités électives on se sent très
proche de certaines personnes la moitié
de l'humanité à peu près c'est des
femmes donc l'idée qu'on va dire ouh là
là attention c'est sûr qu'on a des
sentiments m'associe dit j'ai gardé
jusqu'à maintenant mais veut monastique
à 73 ans bah voila je crois que c'est
râpé de fuir comme ça honnêtement ça
vous a apporté quoi cette chose de thé
alors si vous voulez c'est pas seulement
la chasteté c'est le fait que si j'avais
une famille et des enfants comme
j'aurais pu la voir je serais
probablement encore ainsi pasteur aucune
n'est pas l'idée de partir dans
l'himalaya pendant cinq ans tout seul
dans un ermitage comme je lé fais au fil
du temps c'est pas très sympa pour la
femme et les enfants bon donc si vous
venez ça donne une liberté incroyable
j'aurais jamais pu faire tout ce que
j'ai fait pendant 50 ans dans l'himalaya
si j'avais eu la responsabilité d'une
famille élever des enfants l'incroyable
quand même matière higuain c'est que les
maîtres et les lamas bouddhiste n'ont
pas d'obligation de chasteté enfermé
deux mètres principaux les premiers
kangoo y aurait un beau chèque de 15 mo
j avais une famille c'était le yogi
alors je n'ai pas fait ce voeu de
monastique comme le dal et la malle l'a
fait par exemple c'est un choix de vie
un choix de l'obligatoire des savons ça
vous n'êtes pas forcément d'atteindre à
l'éveil simplement ça simplifie
d'existence pour sûr
[Applaudissements]
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu